[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 183 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark merchandani and I'm here with
my colleague Gabby Ferrara hey Gabby
hello mark how are you I'm doing well
how are you doing good
I've been away but I'm good I feel like
we haven't chatted since the last time
we did a podcast and it feels like it's
been at least a month no I wasn't next
to so I think it was like two months ago
three months ago and that feels like
years ago so it has been quite a while
yeah today we're gonna be talking about
Google cloud platform you acts very
exciting looking forward to that but
before we get into that content we do
want to tease our little question of the
week here and I think this is when you
know a lot about because I'm really not
certain of it which is you know there's
been a lot of cool stuff about cloud
build and cloud run but what is like the
simplest way for me in Google to work
with these containers and then actually
push them up to the cloud well tell you
all about later how you can make your
job easier with the containers to deploy
on your Cobra deities and cauldron
installations so I'm looking forward to
that but I do know that before we even
get to our main content we also want to
talk about our cool things of the week
[Applause]
okay.you cancer
okay perfect don't worry I've got plenty
lined up here the favorite cool thing
I've had for this week is a recent blog
post that was talking a little bit more
about committed use discounts so if
you're not familiar with what they are
they're basically a way of setting up a
reservation and saying I'm gonna use a
certain amount of cores or memory or
local SSD or even GPUs over the next one
year or three years and when you do that
you end up getting those resources for a
little bit cheaper so if you've got
these large static workloads
then it might make a lot of sense to say
okay well I know I'm gonna be running a
medium CPU maybe two CPUs over the next
year so why don't I go ahead and pay a
little bit less for them and then
there's also now a report that you can
actually look at an interactive
dashboard that kind of shows you where
your commits are being used and you can
look at it per project per region and
say okay well you know this is a good
candidate for me to set up a committed
use discount here because I've got all
these cores that I'm statically using so
I find that report really exciting and I
think a lot of people can use that along
with just the general ability to save
money I think people are gonna like it
cool save me money nobody complains
about that actually yeah kind of a
universal like everybody likes to save
money yeah so what I have to talk about
it's part of what we were talking before
in the podcast on the network part so
it's a blog post that came out on the
main blog post that we have on Google
cloud talking about how Google as a
named leader from the data security
portfolio vendors from 2019 report
increases your network security in the
cloud by using three main ways of course
I mean other ways to do so but those are
the three main ways they're go in depth
on the blog post which are security your
internet facing services secure VPC for
private deployments and micro segment
access to your application and services
I think the latter one it's like what we
call IIM so take a look and see how you
can make more secure your deployments on
cloud yeah I think this is another post
in that same line of blog posts that you
just mentioned the networking in-depth
series that just kind of deep dives on
some of these cloud networking
principles especially for people who may
not be as familiar with the cloud it can
be tremendously helpful I don't know
anything about that
well then perfect it was a great place
to start one other thing that I recently
didn't know anything about and now still
only know just scratching the surface we
also have a cool little article about
building chat BOTS using dialogue flow
so dialogue flow is kind of if I
describe this correctly it's really like
the way to build a chat interaction
system right so you can understand what
people are saying and then kind of
create responses and you can use some of
the machine learning aspects there's
actually another really really cool
playlist called deconstructing chat BOTS
that I highly recommend on the Google
cloud platform YouTube channel that goes
into a little bit more detail about
dialogue flow and some of the other
tools around it but we've also got a
team-based chat tool called hangouts
chat which is what a lot of us use here
internally and at people who use G suite
have that so they can kind of
communicate between their teams share
messages and information well you can
actually build a chat bot with dialogue
flow and easily integrate it into
hangouts chat so now if you've got like
repetitive work systems or things that
you need to do on a regular basis I mean
I think the most common one that we
probably use here is searching for
hilarious animated gifs and then
inserting them into Chad a very common
use case but you know I built one or two
test ones you know it's very cool to
think about how can I automate certain
things whether that's going to be like
setting up a meeting or even like
aggregating votes on things like I think
there's some cool possibilities there so
it's super super cool to see yeah like
alerts oh the system's going now yeah
notifications and alerts yeah so you
don't actually wake up people at 3:00
a.m. in the morning if people are
already awake on the chat you don't need
to worry about that
okay and the other cool thing of the
week that we have it's in regards to App
Engine we updated the runtimes
for several languages and one of them is
Java this running now the latest
long-term support version which is 11
although it seemed better yet and also
updated the versions for go for 112 and
PHP now the latest one which is 7 3
which will give you more performance and
don't forget you can all use all of
those new runtimes on your free tier on
App Engine so just click on the link and
give it a look
so lots of new options for people who
are using App Engine or people who
haven't started using it yet you know
they keep adding I feel like every
couple of weeks we see more and more
runtimes and more and more support added
so hopefully that'll kind of catch a
wider audience of people who are able to
use App Engine yeah because like their
languages there have like LTS versions
like every month so hard to keep it up
you know exactly so the more support the
better I think another thing that people
like besides saving money is support for
the favorite languages and staying on
top of those versions yeah
because also there is the part of
security you know if you're running an
older version probably there is no bugs
and that's not cool absolutely well
that's some very very cool things of the
week but I think we should get right
into our main content with Michael
product designer I think this will be a
really fun one yeah yeah I'm I'm really
interested to know how we do things on
UX and Google Cloud let's do it
so we are here today with Michael
Clayman his product designer on Google
cloud platform for you acts Michael tell
us more about you what do you do
hi thank you for having me like you said
I'm a product designer on the Google
cloud platform team
before joining cloud I worked on the
Android and also the YouTube team in the
Bay Area and I moved to New York two
years ago so that's the time that I
started working on cloud first leading
the UX for cloud firestore which was
touching a little bit on Google Cloud
console but also the firebase console
and after that product launched I moved
to the centralized design system team
for cloud team that supports you know
like all the system components for the
UI on the cloud console and if I
understand correctly you've also
actually been doing this for a couple of
different years from before you joined
Google right
yes I had the opportunity to touch
design systems since 2010 or 2011 and
prior to Google and I was working on
Microsoft Xbox it was like the initial
work that was happening with Kinect if
you remember and so we had to like do
the whole design system for this new
input which was like you know body
gestures and like everything had to work
quite differently it was same for
Android because I was part of the team
that worked on Android TV was the first
time that we were kind of like forking
the OS to like you know work on
different platforms and different device
form factors so we had to also rethink
what is the new design system like how
do all the components and UI widgets
like now work for the TV can like very
familiar when I started working on that
in the cloud platform how does one
become a product designer like what did
you do in college what attracted you to
this field yeah that's a good question
because I did so many things before like
landing in UX I think my background is
in 3d motion graphics and new media so
like everything that was happening back
in the day with like flash interact
website you know like I was doing like
cd-roms with micro media director all
the like ancient stuff and I worked on
an agency where our job was yeah just
like an agency we took care of all the
clients needs including branding logo
design motion graphics web designs all
sorts of things so it was like really
good for me to just like get a breath of
work in graphic design and just like
design in general and that's real like
at that time it was starting to become
like a more defined role like
interaction designer and so I moved at
that point to Seattle and started
working for Microsoft and they were like
actual interaction designers there and
so I thought like well this is falling
from heaven almost like everything that
I've liked in the design world so far so
like all families up into this like
amazing role of becoming like
interaction designer thinking about you
know like everything end to end from
visuals to like audio to like flows and
mental models and psychology and
research and I just fell in love with it
and so like ended up like following that
path to what I did today so this is a
question mostly born of my own ignorance
but how come nobody appreciates
interaction design and is that correct
because I kind of get the feeling that a
lot of people don't think about it first
and foremost and in fact don't think
about it at all sometimes but isn't that
result of good design if you don't think
about it as a user yeah I think that's
right like if it becomes like the
interface is invisible and interaction
designer has worked on that so hard to
just like really get out of the way then
yeah you should strive for that but yeah
I guess like that's the other angle of
that question like for example I don't
know like if you have a start-up you're
thinking oh we need designers because
it's like the trend right we just see it
everywhere and you just happen to hire
visual designers because you think
that's all its encompassing right I've
seen a lot of likes and errors like that
yeah you end up having you know like
some gaps I've known a lot of like
visual designers that end up like under
sending so much of everything and they
know how to prototype and their skills
are just amazing but some you know are
just like kind of like coming out of a
background that is just very focused on
that and so like you can't really expect
to have a visual designer think about
like all the other aspects of all the
other design disciplines so I agree with
you sometimes it's easy to think that
yeah the disciplines are all the same
right but not like this is what you have
like a specialized motion designer a
sound designer an interaction designer a
visual designer and so forth so how
designing systems that Google works for
you how is this process so I guess
there's like two audiences right like
for me who I'm trying to build a design
system on top of material design I'm
having to sort like build you know like
a context between what Google uses and
then what products that are built on top
of Google are using right then there's a
designer you know like that actually
consumes what we currently have
under Google material and they just go
to like a web site like material i/o
which is you know like where you just
find guidelines for all the patterns and
all the components but so in my case
when I joined cloud firestore what I had
to do was adopt material design for the
first time nobody in cloud had any parts
of the UI in the material design
language it was still you know I think
called Kennedy like before they launched
the material design so it was really
tough because he was like the very first
product that was trying to do that and
it was still catching up because at that
point they were launching already the
second generation of material design and
we were just like trying to start with
the first one and to take a step back
here could you define material design
yeah sure so material design is kind of
like the first design system that it was
like driven by Google to understand how
the components and patterns work across
different types of devices for different
screen sizes so
there were other design systems out
there like bootstrap things like that
where you have you know like a library
of widgets or a library of components
where like a designer a developer can
just like start using as boilerplate to
create any website but nobody had really
like thought okay now we're looking at
you know watches and phones and TVs and
everything and how would a design system
that spans across multi-device platforms
would work and I think that's how it
started
gotcha so you were talking about how you
were working with the cloud team in
helping them implement design but they
hadn't really caught up to material
design that's right
specifically talking of the Google Cloud
console Forrest's where I don't know if
you guys were familiar with firestore
but it lives in both consoles firebase
and cloud right so there's completely
different design languages there
firebase I think they were a little bit
of head they were already adopting a
material design you know like the
roundness of the buttons they already
like look like material design and the
negative space the whitespace that you
would see on every single page was like
already like speaking that design
language and on Google Cloud we we just
hadn't got there and so like that was
kind of like the first thing that I did
as I was like building the UX for
firestore I was also like trying to
figure out how do we just like to start
implementing all these new components
that are coming from material design so
all of these creative ways you do to
make UX design for the user how do you
reach out those conclusions is that a
design process is there research what do
you do
so you mean for implementing the design
system yeah like you don't discern like
let's say oh this menu should not be the
size because x y and z and research
shows that this would be worse I don't
know the C just needs to be made and
what do you base those decisions on yeah
so I think the ISO like foundational
level which is what we get from mature
design team they had to go through a lot
of that right like they had to go
through a lot of testing and research to
ya figure out what is the right you know
size for a button or like the tap target
for you know making it work on all
different devices contrast for
accessibility I guess like that's all
the requirements that have to go for
that design system just like be
published for everyone to start using it
the same goes for clout so like what's
been happening is that the initial
design system that was composed under a
material design was almost like focused
on consumer products and cloud starts
reaching you know like this
new space which is called enterprise
where like you are thinking about
components that are a little bit more
complex like tables that need to account
for millions and millions of columns
with raw data like coming in like super
fast and things like that and that was
not kind of like part of the library of
components so we do the same sort of
like process you know like we tests you
know the functionality of every single
element in that table the accessibility
of it until it reaches you know all the
requirements and then we can say this is
ready for people to use it you kind of
mentioned a little bit just earlier
about accessibility you know Google has
some pretty tremendous accessibility
guidelines built into everything we do
how does that kind of play together with
the the visual design not just visual
design but the instructional design all
the design right like everything you're
building you also need to keep
accessibility in mind how do those kind
of interplay together yeah so it's like
a super top priority for cloud and
Google has like different sort of like
requirement levels that you also might
need to decide as a team like which one
are we shooting for like you know at
least this year or this quarter and
basically I think they fall into primary
use cases like in your product like you
always know like what are the top three
sort of like flows or tasks that a user
comes to your product to to solve or to
do right and focusing on those main ones
could get you to like I don't know
the first or the second level of
accessibility requirements now if you
keep fixing accessibility issues for the
secondary use cases then you can get to
like the next level and we're actually
now thinking what happens beyond that
last level which is really going through
a screen reader for example experience
where like you can actually accomplish
everything you do but it's not a nice
experience you know not as delightful as
I don't know what you would see on
YouTube when you upload a video or
something like that so really like
focusing on how do you really make the
experience like better for people with
any disability and I guess the other
aspect is from the design system point
of view like how do you make sure that
there's a lot of guidance also for
people that are consuming the components
and the patterns that you have an in the
design system like website so not only
at the component level but at the page
level like we already know like people
come to the cloud design system to
create some sort of like page that lists
all the resources like the resources
being like all your virtual machines or
all your buckets from storage or
databases or datasets from machine
learning models like it doesn't matter
what it is we kind of like know the
desert pattern and we provide guidance
for accessibility how to traverse
through the whole page so that's really
interesting because you were just
mentioning that you know cloud even
inside of cloud firebase had already
kind of adopted a lot of these
guidelines and was in a different place
even though firebase is under cloud and
you were also mentioning earlier that
you worked on the YouTube team in the
Android team so these are all different
guidelines and they're at different
places in terms of the material design
what do they do the same and what are
they doing differently and why aren't
they all kind of at the same place yes
with with firebase it's like a very
unique case and I think it does have
like a similarity to YouTube in the
sense that it's it's all part of Google
but they have their own brand right so
like they're not really consuming
material design or Google material
design exactly as
Google product a product is branded by
Google right so YouTube and fibers are
like these two snowflakes and what
they've done is basically they break a
little bit of the style of the entire
design system to fit their brand and it
works like in the case of firebase their
audience has always been almost like
entry-level developers or like even
startups what they want is just to make
it like super easy to just get started
with an app an idea even if it's a
prototype or something and they give you
all the stuff that you need in there to
get started very quick if you scale then
you can almost graduate cross that big
bridge to the Google cloud platform to
then you know start using all the other
bells and whistles analytics and machine
learning and all that stuff the
difference that I've seen for example on
cloud and you know all the other
products specifically Android and
YouTube where you draw this difference
between the consumer world and then the
enterprise world and I think we all
empathize with consumer right like it's
it's all the apps that we use Google
Maps everything we use today and so it's
kind of like I think easier to ask a
cross-functional team you know like
design something that is easy to use
like when you have PM's and engineers
and designers and researchers and the
entire team is all like really focusing
on making it super easy with the
enterprise for all it's a little harder
right because not everyone's gonna be
using machine learning model and Google
cloud like I don't know how to do that
so it starts getting like I'm kind of
tough right so there's a lot of like
preconceptions I feel like how much
information do you need in the screen or
like is this you know ok for data
scientist like there are things that we
don't know it's still very very early
for us to start figuring out you know
how the consumer and enterprise or like
products should merge and should you
know like start thinking the data
scientist is no different than my mom
that is using YouTube right like we're
just humans like how do you make it
simple and
assistant for anyone in my knowledge of
enterprises most of them have people in
them right mm-hmm
and people tend to be the same maybe
that's a bad assumption I would have
thought that the design principles would
apply equally but I guess it sounds like
as you're saying there are a lot of
different factors to take into
consideration when designing these
systems for almost different personas
that's right
is there any resource you would like to
share about the job you do if people
want to get march in depth in the
subject
you mentioned material design I think
it's one of the sources but what people
should be looking for to make their
product more accessible and more
efficient like here we have the
guidelines as you mentioned for cloud
for YouTube for firebase but on your
opinion where can they get more in depth
and like adopt best practices would be
best practices I think for product
design I think the material dot IO
website is like a really good place to
select stay up-to-date they're updating
that website like frequently and yeah
just just adding you know like all the
new hotness that you know my designers
or even teams that don't have designers
should be like learning from so I think
it's that's like a really good resource
I know other accessibilities would like
centralized websites within Google but
not entirely sure outside of Google yeah
I think it's interesting because there's
no universal this works for everybody
design there's no Universal this kind of
works for everybody accessibility you
said you worked at a couple of companies
including Microsoft and then maybe a
smaller agency before working at Google
what does that look like when you go
from one place to another and how does
that kind of influence your thought
about the design systems that you're
building
yeah it's crazy how like moving to like
big corporations like you feel the
difference also like at that point like
you're not just designing something and
trying to make it you know like fit your
needs but you have to start with sort of
like trying to
on how to consume the already in place
design system so that's like one of the
goals of design systems like you
supposed to like build new things that
are coherent with the rest of the design
language or family of components right
that's definitely like a big difference
that you would feel from like a start-up
or like a place where you're still not
there in terms of clear plan to reuse
components as much as possible but
you're just like early phases of
building and I think building reusable
components come like much after so it
does feel quite different when you when
you join a big company and then all
those reusable components are already in
place what you were talking about with
you know kind of going to a new company
and joining all their assets but we've
seen and this harkens back to you
working at Microsoft you're talking
about the Kinect because it was very
interesting when the Kinect was out
people who don't know the Kinect was I'm
not sure if it's actually still around
if they're still working on it as a
separate tool but it was a peripheral
that you could attach to your Xbox and
it would read you with multiple cameras
and you could basically interact with
your Xbox through hand motions and
gestures and a microphone as well so it
was a brand new paradigm for interacting
with your TV at that time because most
people were playing games with
controllers and we saw a really
interesting kind of almost two
interfaces mixing together when you had
your controller level interface and then
you had the Kinect interface and I think
after the Kinect was out for a little
while they kind of almost merged those
together or they tried to create an
interface that worked for both and I you
know I had a Kinect and I had an Xbox
and I you know I play a decent amount of
Xbox I thought it was really interesting
because some of the design decisions in
my opinion were actually worse on the
controller side because they had tried
to fold in the Kinect one so that's a
very you know concrete example but I
guess you know in in terms of the long
story there the question is is how do
you make those kind of decisions
especially when you're talking about
adding a new redesigned yeah that's like
an interesting story where like we were
just like
dealing with an unknown right like no
one had ever done like hand body gesture
you eyes and there was like nowhere else
to go and find references or inspiration
or research that was like applicable to
what we're trying to do so I think what
was happening also was like hypothesis
that it was like the best way for you to
start using the UI pick the game or pick
the movie or whatever you were trying to
do and that way you wouldn't have to
pick up the controller but I think even
the tagline was like you are the
controller or something like that and it
turned out that yeah it was it was not
nice to use your hands to get to the
content you were looking for
so it was like better to use the smarts
of Kinect to play games because he was
challenging right like if you were
playing like I don't know like a tennis
game you're using your hands and and you
were missing or losing like it was fun
right they didn't matter cuz like you
were just like excited to just continue
playing
but that same mental model doesn't apply
for you trying to find a movie or a game
in the UI it's frustrating
so I think that's when they deviated I
really didn't know what the answer is
today because I haven't played in a long
time but they deviated and when do you
use each controller for what or each
input is good for certain things and how
do we make sure that we teach people
when to use each and what are the
strengths of each of the inputs that
we're offering people I would love to
see a follow up conversation
I mean I'm assuming you still have some
contacts but could we just get someone
from Microsoft someone from Sony someone
from you know we all just sit down in a
room and like hyper analyze their video
game platforms and talk about the design
all right v2 we're gonna leave that one
to you awesome well thanks so much for
joining us Michael and teaching us a lot
about kind of a thought process that
goes into design my pleasure
thank you thank you Michael very cool
talk with Michael super super glad that
he had a chance to sit down with us and
tell us a little bit more I wouldn't
have really known I mean product
designer it's it's such a Corton part of
what
literally everyone uses when they have
to use the platform so I think it's
really fascinating to see look there's a
lot of thought that goes into these
decisions and responsibilities and
implications here of decisions that
people do so that was very enlightening
so in another form of enlightenment I'd
love to ask the question of the week so
my question was really about how to work
with containers locally and then kind of
put them in the cloud so we know that
you know you can build a container using
docker and then you have to submit it
and then you have to pull it up and then
you have to use a build system and then
you have to put it in the cloud that
seems pretty complicated could you kind
of walk us through what of those steps
are necessary and what makes sense so
when I first started with kubernetes for
instance and I did not know much about
docker and in fact used to be a thing
that I love to hate because I didn't
understand how it worked and now I do
I think either set up it how it works
and a lot of the manual tasks I
discovered can be really simple if
you're using the cloud for instance if
you're running a code locally and let's
say you're in a place you don't have
good internet and you cannot do those
dark pools to download all those images
neither to push your image to the cloud
so you can deploy into cauldron or
kubernetes for instance or even a
compute engine so what you can do and it
saves a lot of time from your terminal
you can use the build comment from G
cloud and say to submit the code that's
on that root folder and once you do that
it's gonna do for you that darker build
the darker tag that darker push and in
the end send it to container registry
it's gonna be available for all your
projects on GC P so you win-win
situation you know you don't use your
internet you just use Google whose
internet to do for you and everything
else is just fun then you just can
deploy into communities on compute
engine or even on cauldron just with
simple command lines so I
using called build it's gonna save a lot
of development time on your day-to-day
tasks yeah I mean it sounds like a
one-line command that replaces probably
five or six different processes all of
which had their own little nuances when
you had to run them so super happy to
see that it's a lot simpler than
hopefully it used to be yeah you don't
need to have that much knowledge of
cloud build you don't need to create
fancy things if you just want the basics
and usually when you're creating proof
of concepts that's just enough and that
helps a lot if you want more it can zing
it's a bit on the documentation that's
on the blog post yeah I think we've seen
some pretty cool customization to it
that you can set up really complex build
pipelines but it sounds like even
without setting anything up just the
ability to speed up container building
and deploying is awesome I agree because
nobody wants to stay there pushing an
image to the Internet over 3G or plain
Internet as some universal truths this
episode right everyone likes money
nobody likes to spend time wasting it
doing nothing I think everyone can
relate to this episode so I know we're
almost out of time here so where are we
going to be Gabby you have any traveling
coming up not for a few months I'm gonna
be staying here in New York just doing
my stuff you know I've been looking at a
couple of calendars and I think that is
going to be the reoccurring theme of our
entire team here yeah I mean I'll pretty
much be staying in the Bay Area I'll be
filming with some more customers but in
this case it'll be down in South Bay
which is thankfully pretty close to San
Francisco so I'd still call that pretty
local and then Brian ah John Michell
John Mark everyone seems to be staying
pretty close to their home offices I
don't know mark just announced some
conference I don't know when is it
travel day no idea so relatively quiet
and then hopefully the next time mark
Mandal is on he can tell us a little bit
more about where he was going yeah yeah
curious to know more about it awesome
all right well thanks everyone for
listening and we'll talk to you all next
week talk to you next week
[Music]